before i begin i feel it is necessary to
point out that the news arm of the bbc
has yet to retract apologize or
otherwise address the deeply transphobic
reporting it has engaged in in the last
few months in a pinned comment down
below you'll find my original video on
the topic several videos from the
youtuber sean who has been ongoing in
his pursuit of trying to get the bbc to
own up to what they have done and also a
video from laura kate dale showing the
protests that have taken place outside
of the bbc offices while i don't feel
any of the people behind doctor who are
in any way responsible for this i cannot
in good conscience talk about a bbc
owned property without mentioning this
first until such time as it is properly
redressed thank you
says here the colonialism of white
people caused a massive problem that
sells ramifications to this day
oh that doesn't track
[Music]
continuing on with my re-watch for
series 11 and we've arrived at one of
the better regarded by
quite a few people and myself
demons of the punjab
this is one of the ones that i remember
when the series was all said and done i
felt like this was a more solid piece of
work than what i tended to think a lot
of the other episodes were
now if you're following me through this
you'll know that i am finding uh some
more things to like that i hadn't
noticed before
but i'm also finding some issues or at
least recognizing some things that will
become issues that wasn't the case last
time so it's kind of this isn't doing a
lot to shake my uh previous overall
assessment of series 11 so far and when
it comes to demons of the punjab
it might even slightly worsen my
assessment so
it's not as solid or as strong as i
remember it being
is basically what it comes down to i do
think there is a very important element
of it that does work and actually i'd
say it's probably the thing that they
needed to nail the most for this to work
at all and i do think it gets that right
and that counts for a lot but
there's a there's a
fair number of stumbling points
in this there's just
the somewhat awkward setup of things
with things like yaz's grandmother
having this whole thing of here take
this watch which means so much to me no
i won't tell you why
i don't want to talk about it anymore
like i i can head canon that like she's
just that kind of a headstrong woman who
just wants people to do what she asks
them to do and not ask questions about
it like maybe but at the same time it
just it feels like a contrived setup for
the entire thing there's other little
things like the fact that the watch is
broken because it was just dropped in
the process of
prim passing it over to umbreen that's
that's weirdly anticlimactic and not in
a way that it feels like it says
anything like you can use an anti-climax
to make a point
this doesn't really
feel like it does
there's the fact that these
demons i forget what the actual
species name is but they
they bear a pretty strong resemblance in
function to testimony from twice upon a
time now
the nuts and bolts logistics are
different enough but
in terms of the functionality and also
narrative use and i think that's the big
thing because like there isn't
inherently a problem with doctor who
revisiting an idea or even taking an
idea kind of explored with one race and
grafting some of the themes and notions
and
um just general ideas onto another like
a good example for me that worked or at
least when this second species was first
introduced
the weeping angels
a lot of what goes on with them or at
least the core idea of them the idea
that the minute you stop looking at them
you are definitely dead
that's kind of repurposed with the
silence which as a foe
had issues later on but when they were
first introduced despite that similar
baseline functionality in terms of how
it worked the overall narrative use of
them was very different because whereas
the
uh the angels were
you know something that was you know
we're just dealing with one or even when
it was a group of them they are sort of
scattered they're just trying to gather
resources for themselves whereas there
was a sense of
conspiracy of greater purpose behind the
silence so despite that similarity in
conception their function was different
enough that i
for me at least that didn't bother me
it bothers me here though one partly
because of it has not been that long uh
there are that many episodes prior
from when this aired
from when twice upon a time
came out
so there's that but even aside from that
the other thing is that
the actual core function
is espectively the exact same as
testimony in both cases narratively they
serve as a fake out villain
it's not an evil plan
i don't really know what to do when it
isn't an evil plan
the doctor encounters these beings who
are tied to death
believes them to be sinister turns out
to be wrong and they're much more about
honoring the dead again specifics vary
somewhat but
it's the exact same little mini arc in
terms of their threat i have to stop
them oh they're not a threat
and you know what they're doing is a
good thing it's not only like similar in
terms of the mentality of the testimony
and these and this other species which
it's starting to bug me now that i can't
remember the name um i'm gonna blame
chibnall i can never remember any of the
names he comes up with
it's it's not actually his fault i'm
being petty there but that similarity is
not just in terms of some of the the
nuts and bolts of you know being tied to
death but the whole arc
that the doctor has and the whole
relationship that the doctor has
with them it's
it's very very similar
uh to a degree that's
kind of distracting
so
that there are these just clunky bits
and
the ending
also it it doesn't i feel like the
the scene is misplayed or possibly
mis-edited depending on the the takes
that they took so
early on umbreen you know yaz's
grandmother
doesn't want to tell yas what happened
now that in and of itself is actually
kind of important because that's one of
the themes that actually does play out
and work very solidly i'll come back to
it
but then at the end she seems prepared
to open up
and the ass says no
tell me another time and it's a little
weird
because like
she's opening up to you why aren't you
letting her
now having watched it i think what they
are trying for or at least
it's played in this weird nebulous
middle ground easily enough that i can
headcanon this is what they were trying
for because it's what would have made
sense for this to work i think what they
were trying for was that
um umbreen was
yes she was offering but she wasn't
actually ready to share she just felt
bad from having closed down yes before
and is kind of extending an olive branch
but like isn't truly in an emotional
place where like she's actually ready i
think that's what they're trying for but
it's it it doesn't quite read that way
if the actual intention is actually just
as presented which is that it's somehow
a good thing that yes tells her
grandmother no don't open up to me after
i asked you to before
that's weird and i'm trying to give
benefit of the doubt i don't think that
was it i think i think the takes that
they picked in the edit just didn't play
the moment right i think is what
happened there
but for all the stuff that i've now kind
of gone like
this is a little bit of an issue this
doesn't quite work
there are things that do work i think a
lot of the theming is very strong in
this and we've got two major things
we're dealing with
we are dealing largely with
family
in
various ways in terms of um yaz and
umbreen relating to her as a grandparent
there's that
point in your life
and
i think the age of which it happens to
you know people varies but
there's that point
where you realize that
people who matter to you in your life
had this whole other existence well
before you ever born that you not only
don't know everything about you're never
gonna know everything about because you
would have to spend an entire lifetime
learning everything that went on in
their lifetime
and sort of realizing
you'll never truly know everything they
ever went through
and i think that's a
that's a pretty common experience in
various forms for most people at least
those who have
um
you know
parental figures
um yeah it's a grandmother in yaz's case
but you know parental type figures uh in
their life i think that's that's a
pretty common experience that most of us
go through so that's part of it and then
the other is the
breaking apart of families with
um with the brothers
with prem and manish and
those two themes are connected just by
the um
the similarity in terms of both being
familial issues
couching that in um
in the partition of india i think was
really good as a as a choice of a
historical setting
now partition of india is one of those
things that
like i should know a heck of a lot more
about than i do
and you know you it's
that's partly to blame on
the american education system and it's
partly on me for not you know trying to
better educate myself but like i didn't
know about this like i should have known
a lot sooner than i did
so
as someone
who didn't know a ton about it
seeing it not only brought up but having
it be very humanized i think it actually
benefits the story here that unlike say
rosa these are fictional characters in a
real life situation so while we get a
very quick reasonably quick bullet point
on the situation what year is it exactly
same year you have in england
1947
partition
we're in the middle of the partition of
india we don't have to spend a bunch of
time going through
names and dates and the significance of
individual people we can focus in on
these characters we don't need to take a
quiz we just need enough background to
understand what is going on in the
partition and then we just zero in on
these characters in a way that rosa
wasn't able to do because it had to drop
all these names and dates and specifics
it kind of shows that a historical
setting can benefit from fictional
characters because when you're not under
the obligation to get specifics of real
life people correct because you should
get them correct if you're going to have
real-life people but if you don't have
that there it frees you up to just
have the characters
be
just have them
be and interact and be strong characters
which is the one thing this really
really nails that i kind of mentioned at
the start the emotional core of this
especially rooted in the performances of
the guest cast
is really
really solid
the tension
and the breaking of the family that is
happening in this situation
it feels very honest not only about
something that happened in the past but
something that
still happens and i don't mean in india
i mean
families
split
neighbors turn on each other over what
are ultimately
arbitrary designations
despite
in some cases having
been
peacefully coexisting for a very long
time
and like i i know this is a completely
different issue but you know as a
as a trans person who is watching the
country that i live in
turn
harshly
against trans people
who have always been here
and have only ever been anything close
to visible
to the general public
over the last 20 years or so
that sense of
we were living peacefully
what went wrong
yeah
i get it
so
i think the theming of family and of the
breaking of
bonds and of connection and the
putting stock into these
differences and these designations that
shouldn't drive us apart this much
i think those are themes that
interconnect with each other and
complement each other
very well
and despite being set in a historical uh
setting and despite thankfully never
like doing
this thing where it
overtly draws the parallel between
what's happening then to anything more
recent i still feel that connection
and so that's a way in which
um this feels like it it respects
my intelligence as an audience member to
make these connections and see the
applicability and it doesn't feel the
need to
lay it out for me in
plain terms which
makes it land harder for all of the
wonky
logistics and you know slightly iffy
detailing
i really do
feel that the core emotional
storytelling and the performances from
the guest cast here
are really strong
and do those aspects do still hold up i
suspect that's why
when i did like my wrap up and as time
has gone on i think
probably better of this episode than i
am at this moment and i'll probably get
back to that place again because the
stuff that matters
the emotional core and the connections
and the characters
are what stay with me
whereas the logistical things and the
fact that the villains are a little bit
of a retread
it fades away
from my memory
because it doesn't matter as much
this episode does in my opinion nail the
important
things would it have been nice to see it
get more stuff like really nail it like
yeah
yeah no it uh it totally would but
it gets what it definitely had to get if
it was ever gonna work like there are
other things that i could mention you
know for better or worse that i could go
on about you know there's the fact that
it seems very foolish to me that the
doctor leaves yaz alone with her family
members i know the doctor gives her like
a taco like donated from like just don't
leave her with them that's that's this
foolish thing to do um but then on the
more positive side the
uh how are you feeling scene between
graham and yaz is good and solid and
well played and the stuff that graham
says and
the uh the ideas and the notions and the
sentiments that he uh gives to yaz i
really liked so you know there's lots of
things on either side some decent some
some
not working so great but
it's all built around a really solid
pillar
all the other stuff for better or worse
is
built on
really
really solid foundation with a firm
central pillar in the emotional core of
the story
so this is still good
there's definitely like issues and if
you are someone who gets more hung up on
the logistics um and you know the the
narrative specifics
yeah i could see where this wouldn't
land quite quite as well with you but
for me it it got the emotions well
enough
that i still like it
demons of the punjab
what are your thoughts on it whatever
they are drop something down the
comments and let's talk about it
patreon's what pays the bills enables me
to do this as my living and put out
videos at the quality that i do them and
at the pace that i do them because i
couldn't do this
i couldn't do this the way i do it uh
while trying to hold down a day job
so
i appreciate that greatly any amount
you're able to contribute helps but even
if you can't
like share and subscribe
and
links to other things that i do down
below as well if you want to check out
any of that
but
don't worry too much about it
at the end of the day what i really want
you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council
i'm just running the meetings
and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
and credits i gotta shout out my top
patreon supporters so thank you very
much to zubin lutfullah barack oliver
bean melinda walters leota boy tt for
nobulax the poodle idol tracy scrabbat
vincent paul bartolucci angry casper
adam lefty taylor shane ross robin moore
shayla gourley and brendan the rose
couldn't do it without you
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
bye
[Music]